thank you so much for being here great
to see you I saw you I did a tour this
summer with Andy and you were kind
enough to help us out oh I was so
excited to get to be a part of it yeah
what was it's it's great to have you
here and congratulations this is amazing
it's your first book you never did a
book before and then you get a Grammy
nod
uh unbelievable yeah and you've been
doing a big tour yourself for this book
right I just did a you know you do like
Book Fairs and stuff and I was looking
for someone to relate to but you guys
haven't written but
you do a lot of Book Fairs we've read
three
I got a lot of pamphlets out in my van
got published yeah
so you go on that you went on a book
fair and to explain to me because I
don't even know how it works well you do
all sorts of things you know like dumb
talk shows and everything and then you
um
but you have to do little things like
Book Fairs and I was I was sitting at
this book fair and like you have a booth
and everyone has a different booth and
these girls from um The Miz magazine
Booth came over and they're really sweet
and they uh
they gave me a t-shirt it was like this
is where the feminist looks like and um
I'm that was so crappy of me why do you
why'd you get voice yeah did you make
anything seem lame if you go like oh you
planted a tree in Israel you know
the truth is if the T-shirt looked good
on my boobs I would wear it all the time
proudly sure and this is what a feminist
looks like yeah yeah
so um wait I'm sidetracked so these
girls come over to you but they must
they must really like they must really
look up to you you know they're a little
bit excited so they they were like
trying to relate and they go oh we met
the uh CEO of funny or die dick Glover
and I go
I don't know him and then I'm like
what's his name again
they're like dick Glover and I go
[Laughter]
you probably met someone from funny or
die but his name is not dick Glover
listen to yourself
you're representing all
always and they were really embarrassed
and I felt bad scolding them and then I
went home and just for some Giggles I
Googled uh I Googled it
and the CEO of funny or die is Dick
Glover
oh that's too bad uh
uh now I would just think women must
look to you sometimes for advice which
would be a double-edged sword maybe
because what are you gonna say you know
women look to you as a role model uh I
take it on proudly Conan
um I have a lot to say to women tonight
if I can impart anything to women maybe
can we do like a a close on me so I can
really talk to America
and all the women in America
I promise you you do not need vaginal
deodorant
you need a doctor
get back here
you use Simple soap and water and you
get out of the shower and there's still
a rancidish odor
[Applause]
thank you
don't spray perfume on it that's crazy
right
I don't want to brag Conan but um of
course that's what you say right before
you brag
you're gonna follow up that with I don't
want to brag a few people of
and I've been with have told me that my
vagina smells like a um
a peach a peach tree dish
[Applause]